all right good morning everyone oh do we
have a treat for you today I'm going to
publicise for the first time my my
hidden talent of mind-reading and since
this is a magic trick every every
magician needs an assistant and I want
to introduce Billy Moses to you Billy is
a PhD student he already has three
degrees from MIT but he wants a fourth I
guess and so so I'm gonna turn it over
to Billy here and and Billy's going to
sort of set things up I'm just going to
do my thing which is read your minds
okay so go ahead Billy so what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna I have this card
back right here normal card deck
perfectly normal cards they're not in
any weird order you can see them I'm
gonna give five people the opportunity
to pull a card and then give it back to
me they can look at the card then what's
going to happen is I'm going to turn
over four of these cards show you the
final card and then trainees trying and
they try to guess the fifth card well
but what I need you to do is when I'm
gonna guess I need all of you to really
focus on that hidden card I mean in your
heads right
so I can't do individual mind-reading
just in case you guys were worried you
know so if you think I'm running a
terrible colored shirt I'm not gonna
know okay but if you all think of this
this hidden card I'm gonna be able to
guess it but so I need some help
all right okay you're gonna wants to try
pulling some of the cards okay and your
favorite body right yeah all right you
can look at it give it back to me once
you cool anyone else want to pick a card
pick a card there you go and look at the
full deck look at whatever card you want
take it cool
okay anyone else wanna pick a card cool
and pick a card
cool okay get my cards all nice together
okay so five cards I'm going to show you
first and then we're gonna present them
in a fun way for sure you need to see so
the five cards are as follows
we have this wonderful seven of clubs we
have a Jack of Hearts we have seven of
Hearts we have Queen of Spades we have
ten of clubs now for the people who
pulled the carts these are indeed the
cards that you gave me right no one
missed their card in the deck okay I'll
go get Trini alright yep okay the first
card is the seven of clubs the second
card is the Jack of Hearts the third
card is the seven of Hearts the fourth
card is and this is the final card that
Trini will be able to see the Queen of
Spades
now everyone think to yourself you've
got to see the cards the fifth card that
Trini is gonna have think it very
closely in your mind thinks right
definitely a clubs definitely a clubs
okay see and I'm getting I'm getting a
ten of clubs and it is a ten of clubs
alright thank you
[Applause]
all right so I guess I'll have to
confess I'm not a mind-reader but I also
did not cheat okay so this there's an
algorithm here and that you guys want to
know what the algorithm is so you can go
try this out I guess when you go back
home next or whatever at your at your
dorms or with your with your classmates
so it's not as easy as it might seem
simply because the combinations aren't
really in our favor right so if you
think about it there's 52 cards so this
is a regular deck of cards you know it's
as I said there's no cheating here Billy
showed me four cards so which means the
fifth car I could be you know one of 48
right I mean it's completely random you
guys picked these five cards completely
at random so there's there's no way that
that fifth card could be anything
specific okay so what Billy had to do
was in the four cards that he showed me
he really had to communicate one of
specifically you know one of 48
possibilities which is kind of you know
if you look if you think about it the
map doesn't quite work out right and so
if you just say so what what are the
ways how much information could you
imagine communicating in terms of bits
of information right you know in terms
of possibilities or bits how much
information do you think that that Billy
could communicate in these four cards
who's were also picked at random
obviously they have to be specific cards
right he just put them up there right so
so if I have four cards what are the
ways that Billy could communicate
information when you saw what he did any
any ideas
yeah the order the class are plates so
that's that's a great answer but if you
look at the order in which the cards are
placed how many different orderings are
there four cards how many different
orderings four factorial right and that
is 24 right so I'm not quite at 48 yet
right so that's that's a bit of a
problem right so is there something else
going on other than the ordering yeah so
you mean the way he put them up you know
slowed its you know slowly versus
quickly or do you mean something which
was the time in terms of the exposure of
the car sir
[Music]
well that's all part of the ordering I
mean you have to be a little careful
here in that I mean the you can't do
both right I mean you can't constrain
the ordering and then say that there's
24 different orderings the moment you
constrain orderings the number of
ordering strengths right
so I will say that as I said this is a
very legit Rick it's completely
algorithmic we're gonna write code for
it or I'm gonna show you code for it but
there's nothing else other than the
ordering okay he is there's no sleight
of hand there's no hidden communication
you know he didn't stress words you know
clubs meant something or you know spades
meant something else it was just the
ordering okay and so so there's a gap
here in terms of 24 and 48 right and so
what's cool about this trick is we're
actually going to be able to do this
original trick where the fifth card
could be one or 48 because we're going
to do one thing that you probably didn't
notice because we only did the trick
once all right and so let me explain how
this is gonna work with just sort of
randomly picking I'm just gonna pick the
top five cards assuming these are these
are shuffled and you can assume these
things that are at random right so so I
have five cards that I've picked here
and I can you all see them right okay
what what do you what do you notice
about these five cards anything yeah
buddy
right so you're saying the suit right so
it is clear I mean this is true here you
have the seven of clubs and the ten of
clubs right over these the cards that
you pulled out or closed anyway so so
they look pretty similar to the ones we
used but this probably just because I've
been in shuffled the deck but obviously
if you have five cards and you only have
four suits I guess you could call it the
pigeonhole principle from 604 to but
you're definitely going to have a pair
of cards that are going to be of the
same suit right I mean they baby more
than two cards of the same suit but you
guaranteed for any five cards let me
just pick another five that two of them
are going to be of the same suit right
that's pretty much guaranteed and so we
ended up ended up getting clubs again
here and so you have two and four of the
same same suit so so the first thing
that happens in this trick is we use the
first card to give away the suit right
or Billy use the first card to give away
the soup all right doesn't quite I
finished the story here because let's
just say that I'm gonna use the first
car to signify the suit so in this in
this case let's just say I gonna do
clubs now I have a choice here I could a
Billy I could have hidden to and showed
me the four of clubs as the first card
right or vice versa right and keep that
in mind because that's actually
incredibly important right but if you
just say that the first card is going to
signify the suit then let's say the suit
is now out of the picture right so I
know the suit of the card
hominid so I have three cards left
alright and um I got a hidden card I
know the suit of the hidden card but
that card could be the hidden card how
many possibilities are there for the
hidden card now how many possibilities I
mean this is all a random well 13 oh
good point
yeah oh good good good so this is
exactly why I need a tenth of students
okay good so there's 12 possibilities
since one of them was one of them was
shown right so ah
did that help us there are three cards
left and so how many different I mean
the first card is the first card right
so it's no longer part of this
permutations
I can't count it in terms of the
permutations there's only three cards
left and those certainly those three
cards could be ordered in a certain way
but how many combinations or
permutations are there of three cards
only six permutations so again I seem to
have a problem here I don't seem to have
solved the original problem of the 24 to
48 I still have a 6 to 12 gap right so
we're gonna have to somehow cover that
gap all right
and any thoughts give you a little bit
of a hint as to how this gap is going to
be covered when I talked about the 2 and
the 4
how am I going to cover this gap the 6
to 12 gap right
yeah say you mean Billy is gonna say
something yeah so I mean he the only
thing he can do is is give me give me an
ordering of the remaining three cards
right yeah go ahead Kevin right that's
good that's good
a little high limit on the range exactly
right exactly right so what's happening
here is not only do I have the first
card and it's not that the first card is
just giving me the suit I mean that's
the way I said it right but the first
card also has a number on it right the
first card has a number on it so that
number could be an anchor that is going
to help me figure out what the hidden
card is right and what's important to
understand and this is really the last
interesting point with respect to
shrinking these possibilities are these
permutations down is you want to think
about your let me draw this out properly
in nice little circle you don't want to
think about just ascending sequence of
of cards or numbers you want to think
about this as being circular as you'll
see for the following reason
all right so let's just say the ACE is a
1 and so we're gonna think of that as
being the the smallest number so you go
1 through 13 in this case the king is
the 13 all right so that's your number
and so you could you could imagine you
go 1 through 13 so let's just do that
first and then I'll explain to you why I
drew it in a circle
and the first thing that happens is I'm
going to take some card here and I'm
gonna make that the first card right so
I don't care about suits anymore and if
I just picked this another five cards
let's just do this again but there's
another set of five cards and what do I
have here oh I got a I got all hot
mostly hearts okay so let me do
something more interesting this is too
many hearts there right let's do this so
so now I got a 2 and a Jack and I got a
10 and an 8
ok now I'll make this even more
interesting by picking I want to pick I
want to get a hearts card and let's see
how this works
finally all right so so this is what I
have King of Hearts 8 Oh spades etc so
the two cards were the same suit of the
the 2 and the Jack right and so here's
the important thing one of the things
that Billy did kind of in a subtle way
I'm assuming and some of you may have
picked up on it
the very first card that he asked one of
you to pick it certainly wasn't the
hidden card right I mean he got all 5
cards and then he decided which of the
cards was going to be the hidden card
and then took the remaining four cards
and encoded them right and if you don't
do that if you just say this if you if
you this trick won't work if this is the
hidden card okay this trick is only
going to work
as it turns out on if the the hidden
card is a - it won't even work if the
hidden card is a jack okay um and
there's a reason for that
alright and can you can you think of the
reason for that um if you look at the
board can you think of the reason for
that someone other than buddy someone
else what do you see up here so what am
I trying to do in terms of what what
would happen I you guys talked about
Kevin mentioned the distance and things
like that right you know you can call it
the offset so what would happen if I hit
the jack and I did this I did something
like this where I the two of diamonds
was the first card that was put out and
then I tried to encode a number using
these remaining three cards what's the
what's the biggest number that I could
encode I mean in in III I need to encode
lots of numbers right alright so what's
the what's the biggest number that I
could encode here if I had six
permutations and I start with one the
biggest number that could encode is a
six right
sadly the jack is too far away from the
two right if I think of the jack is
being an 11 it's 9 away from the two
right but help me out here what could I
do if I if I flipped it what happens you
can count backwards or what do I have up
there and on the board what do you see
up there on the board I wrote something
that was linear but what what what do I
have up there on the left circular so
you think more moderate Marik
you know think think of this is being
circular okay so what happens is that if
I picked a two energy and a jack and if
I I what I want to do is to go clockwise
okay and
because they're only 13 cards for any
pair of cards it's always the case that
I can choose the first car in such a way
that the hidden card is at most six away
from the first card okay
because you you you could get into a
situation where obviously if I ended up
hiding the jack and exposing the two inw
in code but if I unhide the two and
expose the jack
then I go one two three four and I'm at
basically four okay so so that's the
last thing all right so let's just do
this really quickly with yet another set
of five cards right now obviously we
practice so we could do this fairly
quickly right but and you can practice
too but sometimes it thinks you get
lucky you know and you get easy easy
things to encode right so what happens
here someone wants so now that you know
the algorithm you have some choices here
but obviously you have that not all
choices will work you got to be a little
bit careful what would you what would
you hide so so you need to make sure
that you you get you can choose a pair
of I'll make this a little bit easier
sometimes choices make things more
difficult right perfect
all right so so what you see here is
your you know that you have to do the
clubs now right because you have the the
clubs as being the the suit that's
repeated no other suits are repeated
right so what am I going to expose and
what am I going to hide that's your
first question right someone else you
guys could all gonna have to do this
trick that's the final exam for this
class
okay on Friday next week you're all
doing the trick no all right so what am
I going to what am I going to yeah go
ahead Josh
you're gonna hide the ace exactly right
you you want to hide the ace because you
want to go this way and if you do it the
other way around it's not going to work
you're gonna hide the ace and you're
going to make the king the first card
and and now what you need to do is this
is this is gone right and now what I
need to do is I need to encode a number
between one and six in general in this
case I need to encode the number one
okay in order to give away the fact that
the hidden card is an ace and now I can
do what was suggested before we just
have some sort of I mean there's
obviously an ordering associated with
with these cards that you see up here if
I call this a1 and I call this the 13
then that let's do the logical thing
which is 1 is smaller than 2 which is
smaller than 13 but I might end up you
know I might have a and nine of Hearts
here rather than a 5 of Hearts and I got
to obviously be able to order the nine
of Hearts in relation to the 5 of Hearts
as well right so because I that all of
these could be nines actually right and
and so so I can't just rely on the
number to do the ordering so I could
just choose an arbitrary clubs is small
the smallest diamonds is the next and
then I got hearts I just did this
because this is a little bit easy to
remember for me you can do this in many
different ways in alphabetical order you
know see DHS and so so this that's
that's moot here what I need to do is to
encode the number one okay and then I
encode that in order to encode the
number one I have to have some sort of
way of ordering this and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say SLM is
one so what do I mean by SLM the
smallest card is is first the I'm sorry
SML is
increasing this the smallest card is is
the first one the medium card is the
second one and the largest card is the
third one okay and I'll write this out
and you can see the code for it but when
you see something like L LM s you're
going to get a six and there's obviously
six of these different combinations
right
the details are actually entirely up to
you I mean the most important thing here
is the ordering that Billy had had to be
the ordering that I had alright and so
yesterday when we practiced one time
there was a mismatch and we got it wrong
but that's the only way the trick would
would fail I really I mean other than
human error is if the is the encoding
this is really encoding followed by
decoding and obviously you need the same
algorithm if you will which requires
that you need the same ordering in this
case for the for the cards right so so
that's it that's that's the trick um it
doesn't seem that interesting anymore
huh but no it is interesting if you show
it to people and and the fun part is
didn't and actually doing it so I
encourage you all to do it any questions
about how this trick works so what I
like to do is show you some code for for
this trick and there's also a code that
was useful to both of us because we
could practice by ourselves we didn't
have to be in the same room to practice
because I could sort of randomly
generate a bunch of these four cards and
obviously the program knew what the
hidden card was and I could you know
I'll show you the code I could type in
what the hidden card was and we it would
say you know I guess I'd say you're a
mind-reader extraordinaire or sorry not
impressed and then Billy could do the
same thing in terms of checking is n
coding
alright and then after we're done here
talking about the code and there's some
interesting things with the code it
let's talk about whether you could talk
about different kinds of tricks and in
particular I want to talk about whether
we could go from five cards to four
cards
using a different encoding scheme right
so cool so I wrote this code about a
year ago and I think I'd probably write
it differently now
but we have what we have so the first
thing is you have to decide on an order
right you absolutely have to decide in
an order and the cards themselves as I
mentioned I'm this natural order
associated with the numbers and of
course you can decide if you want to
start with the with the two and then
yeah and the ace could be 14 I mean kind
of makes sense to for you to go 1
through 13 so that's really what we have
here the ace is the smallest card and
the King is the biggest card and as I
mentioned I the clubs are smaller than
the diamonds etc so I just have a deck
of cards that is ordered as you see up
there and that's just a Python list that
tells you what the ordering of these 52
cards are right that makes sense so the
so the there's many procedures here many
routines that do different things and a
lot of them use the same code so I'm not
gonna explain each each one of them but
this one is the is a good one and I'll
also show you the computer assistant one
which is essentially this procedure
except that it allows it allowed me to
practice by myself and I generated cards
randomly in this case what happens is
you input five cards and what this does
is so you could sort of take five cards
out from the deck and then manually you
can you can choose the hidden card order
the remaining four and if you typed in
those five cards into this particular
procedure it would give you the first
four cards okay and so you can then
verify that you've done the ordering so
this would be something that I don't
have Billy used this to practice but he
could have so what do I have here well
the first thing is just printing out
what the order is
there's a bunch of things that need to
get initialized cards is simply a list
of five cards and and then you have C in
index or CN which is the indices in that
in that giant list that we have that had
52 cards in it it's there just the
indices of the various cards you can you
can use dot index which is a method to
go from a card which is like a
underscore see for example to the to the
index and and then card suits are what
the suits are for the cards and it's 0 1
2 & 3 for clubs diamonds etc and then
the numbers are what the numbers of the
cards are 1 through 13 okay I kind of
need this there's a bunch of bookkeeping
as you can imagine you know if you're
doing things in our in our head here but
if you want to get a computer program to
actually do all of these computations
it's not complicated but you have to
worry about the four suits and you got
to worry about the 13 cards and you have
to go ahead and encode SML or produce
this encoding right so you can imagine
there's a bunch of code it's not
complicated code but there's a bunch of
code right so the first thing that
happens here is in this particular
procedure you want to input these cards
in and so let me just run it and and so
you get a sense of what this procedure
does alright beautiful so let's just say
let me just pick five of these here so
first one is five hearts I'm sorry five
of five of Hearts yep five hearts nine
of diamonds jack of spades ten of Hearts
and so it essentially says the first so
if I have something like this it ended
up choosing you'd end up choosing the
ten as the hidden card and decided to
choose five as the first one and then
because ten was the hidden card you
needed to encode five right and
so so the way you encode five is is by
encoding L s and M so the first card
that should should be up is a jack
followed by the the smallest card which
is an 8 followed by a 9 okay that's
essentially it so now that you've seen
that let's let's take a look I'm not
going to go through every line of code
here I want to point out if a couple of
things that that are interesting this is
simply I filling in that data structures
the only thing that's interesting here
or the thing that's probably the most
interesting here is what I've
highlighted this is a way of taking an
element in a Python list and getting the
index for it and so that's essentially
something that it's object-oriented
programming we probably won't get into
that in in this class but you'll
definitely see that in Dublin EIN and
other classes and essentially what we
have here given the ordering is the the
the suits simply correspond to whatever
the indexes mod four because as you can
see from this clip clubs are this is 0
the index 0 and the next the next Club
is it is index 0 1 2 3 4 so you're going
to get mod of clubs is always going to
be mod 4 of clubs is always going to be
a 0 mod 4 of diamonds is always going to
be a 1 etc right so that's essentially
what happens here and the first thing I
need to do is figure out two cards that
have the same suit because that's
important because that's going to
determine what my first card is and what
my hidden cards are and that's what
happens over here and then once I have
that I need I've sort of split these
five cards into two piles one of which
has the the hidden and the first card in
it and I'll the other pile has the three
cards that correspond to the ordering in
it obviously the computations that I
have to do for the first couple are
quite different from the ones for the
the remaining three cards in one case
it's ordering in the other case is the
comparison and I do have two the most
interesting remaining part of the code
that I'm going to show you is the
determination of what the hidden card is
and what the first card is and that's
going to require this is the part that
actually took me the longest to code I
got it wrong a couple of times it's
going to require me it's five lines of
code but it's subtle he's gonna require
me to kind of figure out whether it's
the jack where's the two you know or
weisswurst
right and and things get a little bit
interesting for example if you had if it
wasn't the jack in the two the example I
had here it's illicit let's put the jack
into let's say I had a three and a ten
right um they're kind of the furthest
apart and you have to be kind of super
careful here because you know three to
ten is obviously seven which is too
large but you need to go ten to three
which is six right so the things that
are diametrically opposite to each other
are usually the hardest when it comes to
actually doing the trick but it's all
there was off it was also hard from a
standpoint of coding I had to get the
mods right and and the subtraction the
and and in in terms of what got
subtracted from the other so so the rest
of it is I just have a high level
descriptions obviously the code for
these individual subroutines is is in
the file as well but this one determines
what's hidden what the other card is and
what the number that you need to encode
is so when you go do the split and you
have the two cards you obviously need to
decide which one goes first which one is
hidden and you also get the number right
and that number had better be between
one and six otherwise this is not going
to work and then you remove the other
the two cards hidden and other from from
the set of five cards in order to
actually do this SML it was a little
easier for me to sort these cards and
then depending on the number and code I
changed the order obviously if I sort
the cards I'm going to get SML and that
may not be what I want but it's it's
easier to start with SML saying this is
the order that gave me the number one as
an encoding what do I need to do in
order to change that encoding to a 2 or
a 5 or a 6 or what-have-you
okay and so that's what this this output
next three cards does so said this this
is what took me the longest to code
right I mean it was a few minutes but
the rest of it was was pretty much busy
work it wasn't too much thinking so this
thing here as you can see that encode is
don't you need only to worry too much
about the list itself and the indexing
into it the bottom line is I need to
figure out this situation and I need to
subtract and so when I when I see
something that says ten and a three I
end up getting a seven and then I know
that I have to do a flip okay but it
also may be the case that I might get
something that I the reason I need the
the the Mod 13 is partly because I might
end up getting a negative number right
so it's not clear that encode take away
the Mod 13 is going to give me a
positive number right you know I might
be subtracting 9 from two right so I end
up getting a minus seven right so so you
don't know this I mean the program
doesn't know which one is which and it
has to figure out which one is which and
flip them together so I if there's any
code that you want to look at carefully
it's it's this is this code and it's
just a matter of sort of going through
the combinations and making sure I know
it works but you need to convince
yourself it works all right so that's
pretty much it it's there's not much
more to say here that wouldn't be kind
of obvious to you looking at it
carefully so I don't want to belabor the
obvious and I'll put next three cards is
the part that I just described you start
with sort of the default ordering which
encodes a 1 and then you need to do a
little bit of flipping if you want to
encode a at 3 for example and if you
want to encode a 3 then you change
things around
and this is exactly what I described to
you before right so this is actually
fairly straightforward if you have that
table written in front of you you just
go off and write that okay
certainly if you change the algorithm
you know all of this would change quite
dramatically and that this there's an
exercise which asks you to do that which
you could certainly try to do I want to
show you one other thing which is which
is interesting and and then I want to
run this new subroutine so what I have
here is I'm gonna run I've already run
it so I want to show you
computer assistant which was very useful
to me um and this says please give me a
random number of at least six digits
right so obviously I don't want to know
what the hidden card is if I want to
practice in a legitimate way right so um
so what I did was I said I'm gonna have
this sort of hokey I'm just really hokey
I'm gonna have this hokey algorithm
that's gonna take this giant number that
I'm gonna type in and somehow I'm going
to take this giant number and it it's
going to deterministically generate five
cards based on this giant number okay
but I didn't want to have an obvious way
I mean I don't want to say I'm the
number one two three four five and then
end up getting the first five cards in
the deck or something like that because
that was sort of give it away right so I
want to have some sort of some sort of
obfuscated way of taking a giant number
and generating something that was at
least unpredictable to me in terms of
the five cards that are generated okay
and so what I do is if I type in if I
type in a number you know some some
random number and at this point I have
no idea what the what the five cards are
going to be generated are okay and this
just tell me it does do the assistant
order its cards functionality so it does
take those five cards hides a car right
and then exposes the four cards to me
right and so I'd get different depending
on what numbers I types of
the way I practiced is I just sort of
you know close my eyes and just type
some random number and then it would
produce four cards for me and notice
that this is wonderful
notice that there's a buck right this is
exactly why I put this up and wow what
luck right so so notice that this this
didn't work right you know and that's
the fix that's the next exercise I'm not
I can't do not it's an exercise in that
that's going to be up there which is you
know fix my hokey algorithm so it
doesn't do this okay and so what
happened here was I had a deterministic
way this wasn't a random number
generator that the good way of doing
this would have been to use pythons
random random number generator facility
and not have me do anything not because
obviously I typed something that turned
into into that which is a deck that has
you know - King of Hearts in it and so
so my deterministic way which was a
convenient way because only four lines
of code didn't need me to to include the
Python random Lib library etc causes
trouble right so this obviously won't
work right so I'll just type something
and it's gonna say sorry not impressed
okay I'm not impressed with my guests
and not impressed with my code okay so
let me do this again and so let me just
do that and now what
is this this is ridiculous I mean does
my code even work I'm gonna blame it on
my computer I told you my my laptop was
acting up okay okay one one one two two
two oh thank you all right so so now I I
see this and I say seven of seven of
clubs so that's the first card so
clearly it's the clubs and then ten King
and six right so 10 is the medium so I
got medium/large MLS right so MLS is MLS
would be four right so so four would
give me the Jack of Clubs right there
you go
right so so this worked okay but I'd not
want to show you the last thing I'll do
is show you this code and you guys
should absolutely fix this code it is
clear what your exercises or you could
be I do want to talk about doing this
with four cards so so notice that this
this is the offending line of code okay
so what I did was I wanted to generate
five kind of random looking numbers out
of this giant number that I typed in
right and and I got lazy and I was tired
of this puzzle by the time I ended up
coding it so I just said you know I want
I don't want to include random dot Lib
from Python I'm just going to take this
and I'm going to do some sort of
iterative computation where I'm
generating what I think are our random
numbers between 1 and 52 from this giant
number that I typed in I'm going to do
this 5 times and what happened as you
saw is that I generated the same number
twice a couple of times right and that's
why obviously the trick doesn't work in
that case right what was interesting was
the way I found this bug was not the
obvious way that we just saw here was it
was actually something where it the the
hidden card was the same as one of the
four carbs okay that was exposed so I
didn't know that right so I'm like what
you know
not getting this right right it kept
saying sorry not impressed right and
what it meant was it wasn't impressed
with my coding not with my deductive
skills okay so it took me a while to
figure this out
all right and you can fix it okay so so
that's it any any questions about the
what we've talked about the puzzle or
the code right okay so in the five
minutes that we have left let's talk
about whether they would be a trick
which would be perhaps even more
impressive where we would only use four
cards right so it'd only be four cards I
that the audience selects and we would
Billy I guess would show me three cards
and I'd have to guess the fourth okay I
would that would that be possible
I mean the numbers really you know don't
work right because that that fourth card
I could be one out of I guess if you
show three cards one or 49 different
possibilities and it would be it would
be pretty difficult right I'm you could
you know think about something where the
only way I could come up with
it was required much more encoding but I
was thinking about something like this
right where let's say I have these four
cards right and let's even take let's
let's say that they're all of different
suits right because that's possible what
the other thing that happens when you
have when you only have four cards is
they're all four could be of different
suits right that's certainly possible I
keep
whatever I want I want to heart okay
good so I have something like this and
now I'm in real trouble
right I mean clearly anything that we
talked about isn't going to work right
so let's just say that I that I end up
choosing one of these cards you know to
hide right so there's this ace is hidden
okay because it's not quite clear what
I'm what I can do here but bear with me
for just a minute so for argument's sake
let's say that that now at this point
I'm trying to get more information out
of this the ordering isn't going to help
me I mean the ordering is in is going to
help me a little bit but what am I gonna
get like six you know one through six
from this so I could say the first card
is is an anchor okay and so I'm gonna
expose this so the only thing I could
think of was you could sort of do this
is a little bit obvious and maybe giving
things away but depending on where you
have the hidden card and you can get
more information based on the order in
which you put these cards out and
whether they're to the left or the right
of this of this hidden card okay so you
need to do something like that I mean I
haven't figured this out at least I
can't think of think of a a complete
solution to this puzzle but I do feel
like that you can get some information
additional information based on whether
you put things to the left or the right
and that's clearly a bit of information
that you get and maybe you could add to
that and you know think about it right
it's I think it makes for an interesting
exercise and obviously there's other
ways of doing the five card trick as
well all right cool all right that's all
I had for today if there are no
questions we can close this pretty first
session